is hista DAO, just as good as histamine scavenger.
They're completely different.
So we have a product that's called hista clear.
It is DAO enzyme, which is the enzyme,
which clears histamine, but it clears histamine
wherever it's located, you don't absorb it.
It's too large of an enzyme for you to be absorbed.
So it really is primarily working in the gut itself.
So you would take hista clear or hista DAO enzyme,
other companies make it as well,
to help decrease histamine in the gut.
You don't take it to help remove histamine in the tissues.
So you need other herbal products to remove histamine
from the tissues.
And our histamine scavenger or clear histamine scavengers
is a good one to do that.
We also have natural clear hista,
which is a different mix of combination of things
to do that as well.
You can look at the back of the histamine scavenger bottle,
the website and see the different,
the reason why I like that is it's got a lot of different,
nutrient-tinted that will deal with different pathways.
A lot of products just have corseted
and a few other things that will pull out histamine scavenger
as number of different things.
So the histamine, hista clear or the DAO enzyme,
is completely different than a histamine scavenger
or a natural clear hista that the hista DAO enzymes work.
Primarily in the gut do not get absorbed,
do not pull out histamine from the tissues,
histamine scavenger, natural clear hista are absorbed,
they pull out histamine from the tissues.